et alors que les combats font rage vous
l'avez vu et que l'exode des ukrainiens
se multiplient cette annonce qui nous
est parvenu il y à peu l'ukraine se dit
prêt à des pourparlers avec la russie
des discussions qui pourraient avoir
lieu à la frontière biélorusse pourrait
être à gomel près de tchernobyl des
pourparlers d'ailleurs qui pourraient
intervenir notamment dès ce dimanche
avec nous au plateau pour interpréter
analyser cette annonce notre chroniqueur
international marc perelman nous a
rejoint bonjour market marquent cette
annonce de pourparlers donc je le disais
comment interpréter cette annonce selon
vous est ce qu'il ya une réelle volonté
de négocier de la part des russes en
tout cas c'est la première fois depuis
tout séjour de guerre où il y à un mince
espoir de dialogue on sait que rien que
ce matin le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky avait refusé la
proposition russe de tenir des
pourparlers à minsk en affirmant que la
biélorussie et un état depuis ou son
lancer des attaques contre l'ukraine
s'était totalement inacceptables pour
lui avait proposé d'autres alternatives
en europe en azerbaïdjan en turquie
visiblement les discussions n'ont pas
été rompus à ce stade là elles ont
continué pour arriver à un accord
annoncé par le bureau de monsieur
zelensky et disons que des négociations
allaient se tenir à la frontière entre
l'ukraine et la biélorussie dans la zone
de tchernobyl
reste à savoir où exactement
mais le ministre ukrainien des affaires
étrangères qui parlait lors d'une
conférence de presse à affirmer que oui
une délégation était en route et que ses
suites et ça c'est aussi intéressant
quand même à une conversation
téléphonique entre volodymyr zelensky et
le président biélorusse alexandre
loukachenko
alors que évidemment la tension est
extrême entre les deux ils se sont
parlés le ministre ukrainien affaires
étrangères a affirmé que le président
biélorusse avait affirmé assuré à son
homologue ukrainien qui il n'y aurait
pas de frappe depuis la biélorussie
contre l'ukraine tant que ces
négociations seraient en cours donc
c'est évidemment très fragile très
prématuré mais c'est la première fois
qu'il ya un vague espoir de 10 sion du
côté ukrainien on a aussi affirmé qu' il
n'y avait pas de pré condition à cela
donc reste à voir si cette réunion va
avoir lieu on peut dire une chose c'est
que le président ukrainien n'ira pas en
personne là bas parce que lui même a
affirmé qu'il était en danger oui c'est
la question vous allez vous poser une
crainte pour sa sécurité ne videmment
évidemment et s'il ya une crainte pour
sa sécurité
vu la méfiance qu'il ya du côté
ukrainien sans doute justifiée non
seulement vers la russie mais aussi la
biélorussie on peut imaginer que la
délégation qui a été envoyé là bas ne
comporte pas d'officiels ukrainien de
haut rang mais au moins alors que on
entend des menaces on voit des batailles
pour la première fois il ya un vague
espoir de discussions diplomatiques sera
juste
juste même si ça n'a pas été mentionné
que le président français emmanuel
macron a parlé hier soir à alexandre
loukachenko donc on peut imaginer quand
même qu'il y ait une volonté des deux
côtés qui se battent sur le terrain mais
aussi du côté européen sans doute
américain d'essayer d'imaginer une
sortie de crise pas de résolution
diplomatiques complètes mais au moins
pour avoir une accalmie sur le front
c'est encore loin d'être le cas
évidemment un mois également avec vous
marquez que cette volonté négocier russe
et est assez récente est ce que c'est
l'ailier d'une certaine manière à
l'enlisement mais au progrès moins
rapide que prévu sur le terrain au
niveau de l'ordre leur offensive
militaire ça peut être une
interprétation cependant évidemment on
entend des bruits de bottes y compris
nucléaires du côté de vladimir poutine
presque de façon concomitante à cette
annonce de discussion voilà qu'en tant
il affirme qu'il veut mettre en alerte
la force de dissuasion tout le monde
comprend que c'est une force de
dissuasion a priori nucléaire donc c'est
à peu près ce qu'il ya de pire mais
c'est pas étonnant c'est le jeu de
vladimir poutine de souffler le chaud et
le froid une chose est sûre il espérait
gagner très vite il espérait que
vladimir et dance qui sauteraient dans
le premier avion pour paris pour
washington où pour berlin ce n'est pas
le cas ça se passe moins bien et il ya
des questions qui se pose parce que
pourquoi est-il en ukraine que va-t-il
faire jusqu'où dans quel but final donc
il doit aussi avoir une volonté du côté
de kremlin d'imaginer une porte de
sortie à cette crise qui soit autre
qu'une invasion complète et sans doute
mortifère de l'ukraine